(audience applauding)
- [Kejal] Venezuela unveiled
its new national map in December,
adding an area the size of
Florida to its territory.
But this land called the
Essequibo belongs to Guyana,
a country rich in golden diamonds,
it is now one of the world's
fastest growing crude oil producers.
For more than a century,
Venezuela has laid claim to the Territory
- Annexing Essequibo practically
wiping Guyana off of the map.
- I'm here in Caracas,
trying to understand more
about President Maduro's plans
to take over this land and
what it means in this region
as these two oil-rich countries clash.
- [Kejal] The dispute for the Essequibo
dates back to the 19th century
when Great Britain acquired Guyana
and expanded its Territory to the West.
But Venezuela protested
saying the Essequibo
was part of its Territory
under Spanish rule.
Tensions between the two
countries intensified in 1966
when Guyana gained
independence from Britain.
Guyana has since sought a resolution
through the International
Court of Justice,
but Venezuela rejects the procedure.
The Essequibo makes up
two thirds of Guyana
and is mostly covered in rainforest.
The Territory has large
reserves of gold and diamonds
- Essequibo region contribute
to the country's economic wealth.
Our forest is an important resource.
We have large deposits of gold reserves,
- [Kejal] But a turning point came in 2015
when oil was found off
the Essequibo Coast.
Since then, a consortium
led by the US Oil giant, ExxonMobil,
said it has discovered up
to 11 billion barrels of oil
and natural gas resources.
Oil executives say that
this was the largest
discovery of the decade.
It could give the country the
highest oil output per capita
in the world ahead of oil-rich
Kuwait and Saudi Arabia.
- Guyana it's interesting
because it is a new producer.
It's a country where until 2015,
no one knew that there was oil
and it has started to produce,
and it's a not OPEC member,
which is very important.
And it includes it's
possibility to already
deliver oil to the market in
a market that is restricted
because of all the sanctions
that exist to Russia.
- [Kejal] Because of its
new found oil revenues,
Guyana had the highest real GDP growth
in the world in 2022, 62.3%,
and the International Monetary Fund
predicts its GDP will keep growing.
Guyana went from one of South
America's poorest countries
to having one of the world's
fastest growing economies.
- We are poised to earn,
on average about 5 to $6
billion per annum by 2035.
- But Venezuela's president Nicolas Maduro
says the oil reserves in the Essequibo
belong to his country.
While Guyana reaps from the oil windfall.
Venezuela's economy has contracted 80%
since Maduro came to office in 2013.
Nearly 8 million Venezuelans
have fled in the past decade.
Hundreds of thousands of
them wound up in the US.
In order to oust Maduro,
the US imposed sanctions
on the Venezuelan oil industry in 2019.
The Biden administration
agreed to temporarily lift
some economic sanctions
on Venezuela in October
in exchange for democratic reforms,
which include allowing
opposition candidates
to run in this year's
presidential election.
US officials said that
allowing more oil and gas money
to flow in could help stabilize Venezuela
and ease the large flow of migrants.
But when it comes to
the Essequibo dispute,
Washington is not a Venezuela side.
The State Department
said it supports Guyana,
which has held meetings
with officials from the
US Defense Department
to increase cooperation.
(groovy music)
In December, Venezuela's government
said more than 10 million voters
approved annexing
Essequibo in a referendum.
(protestor speaking in foreign language)
(drum music)
But election experts have cast doubts
on the veracity of the results,
especially in a country
where the government
has been accused of
widespread electoral fraud
in past elections.
(Maduro speaking in foreign language)
- [Kejal] After the referendum,
Maduro ordered the country's
state-owned companies
to explore and exploit the oil, gas,
and mines in the Essequibo,
and told foreign companies
that they have three months
to abandon their operations in the region.
- Guyana views this as an imminent trap
to its territorial integrity
and will intensify precautionary measures.
- [Kejal] As tension started to rise,
the UK sent a warship to support Guyana
and Maduro responded
with air and naval
exercises near the border.
(cheerful music)
Experts said the referendum was largely
a wag the dog moment for Maduro,
as he tries to rally nationalist support
ahead of the presidential
election later this year.
- It's a typical strategy
of a dictator autocrat
of finding a problem to distract
people from their reality,
which is a completely
devastated economic situation
and a horrible humanitarian situation.
- [Kejal] The leaders of Guyana
and Venezuela have met
to discuss the annexation
and agreed to avoid conflict,
but Guyana refused Maud's
plans to settle the dispute
through bilateral negotiations
asking the UN to intervene
and lay Venezuela's claims to rest.
But experts say the case is
likely to drag on for years.
(pensive music)